lucas giolito on the hill tonight coming
off his best performance at quite some
time he's two and two is era in the high
threes adam frazier very good defensive
second baseman two and two from lucas
oh waving a miss strike three first
strikeout for giolito tonight involved
a three era in his five games a zero era
in the four games he started anderson is
at second abril on it first and johan
moncada will come to bat the
and a swing and a
ball caught at short just off the ground
by gonzalez
and that ends the inning so one out base
is empty gregory polanco of the batter
a wave and a miss strike three
so here's jt riddle and the high
fastball here might just put an end to
this one and two for riddle
and it does
strike three third ticket punch tonight
adam angle with rbi ground out tim
anderson an rbi single two nothing white
sox leads first and third and here is
lilo jimenez ground ball right side
that's going to get through for a base
hit
here comes mendic to score
and anderson will stop at second slow
rolling base hit to right field it's
three-nothing white sox three-nothing in
favor of the white sox we go to the top
of the third cole tucker will lead it
off here for the pittsburgh pirates
champ swinging a miss strike three went
right back to it and why not
three straight strikeouts four in the
game here for julio
called strike three a fastball lucas has
five punch outs
getting the sox put second and third on
with one out it's a ball and two strikes
on mccann
in the air left field reynolds back at
the track he's underneath to make the
catch
well khan attacks from third he scores
throw into third not in time and the sox
take a four nothing lead as james mccann
gets himself a sac fly
one and two the count here on reynolds
and that a swing and a miss there's
strike three six strikeouts now for g
alito two outs in the fourth runner at
first base four nothing white sox fourth
inning josh bell who was an all-star
last year and had a marvelous offensive
season
left side a line drive to joanne moncada
it's uh four-nothing socks lucas giolito
has gone four innings he's given up one
base runner on a walk
oh strike three called
cb rang him up
lucas will take that all night long
polanco would hit 12 if that was a
strike all the time
to cole tucker
oh strike three not his tempo certainly
lucas is anything but a double rainbow
tonight four nothing socks over the
pirates top of the sixth inning on one
and two
and that's a swing and a miss it is it
ninth strikeout for geo two down in the
sixth gonzalez the only base runner
tonight for the pirates
to shortstop
t.a
pulls him off the bag the tag is there
jose got it down
for route number three
scoreboard tells the story lucas giolito
shutting out the pirates in a number of
ways it is four to nothing there you see
it top of the seventh inning we're glad
to have you along and lucas giolito
will face frazier reynolds and bell the
third time through
one and two
on the ground second base mendic charges
danny's there one gone
up the middle
tough play tim unloads and got here
oh boy
if this night goes the way you want that
one's going to be replayed hundreds of
times
0-2
swing and a miss so he got the sword out
wizardry from geolito lucas giolito
rolls along
it's gregory polanco to start in the
eighth
he struck him out number 11 for lucas
two balls two
strikes sway gonna miss strike three
three outs to get
the 25th swing and miss for lucas
giolito tonight
two and two
swing
he did go strike three
two outs to get
one and two
in the air right hand side
adam angle is there two down
no hits
through 26 outs
[Applause]
strike one
deep in thought
the well-trained mind of lucas giolito
he wins strike two
one more bat to miss
nobody's here to watch
but everyone
at home
has their hearts
in their
[Applause]
owen
throats
to right field adam engel is there
a no hitter
the 19th
in white sox history
you